冬ですね
冬って冬ってなにかこう
人肌恋しくなりませんか
はああ……触れたい、触れたい！
女の子に触れた…
今回ですね
ペットを飼おうと思いまして
今までこうなんか
ロボットのペットとか
ペットっぽいペットじゃないものとか飼ったんですけど
今回はもうちゃんとしたペットです
今回はこちらです
おばけえび飼育観察キット
２０日間でこういうお化けができる訳ですね
卵からかえって
立派なお化けになると
なんかこういうの小学校の時にやったような気もする
こともない気がするんですけど
なんか凄い面白かった覚えがあります
人肌まではいかないですけど
まあ、ね？ちょっと
ちょっと多少でも寂しくなくなると思って
今回このおばけえびセットを今日から育てます
秋い！？
秋って秋っていつ？秋ってい……
ｲｪｴﾝでも１１月ってぎり秋じゃね
分かんない分かんない
怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い
部屋さえ暖かければいいのか
大丈夫そうですね
一応１１月はぎり秋なんで多分大丈夫です
大丈夫なんですけども
このおばけえび自体が
そんなに長く育つ生き物じゃないらしいです
長期間の成長は見込めないと思います
なるほどおばけえびちゃん自体
そんな長く生きる生き物じゃないらしいですね
卵からかえって大きくなって
結婚するんだね！？卵も産むんだ！？
うううううう
ううん
ガイドブック
このガイドブックにうわーあ
オスメスもあるみたいですね
なんかこういう育てる系好きなんですよね
おばけえびとは、えっと
な、なんかエロいね
塩分を含んだ湖、塩湖に住む海老の仲間です
今から約５億年も前からいた生物です
やばいな　ああ可愛い可愛い
えーえーえーえー可愛い可愛い
こういうのずるいんすよね
こういうイラスト見るとなんか愛着が湧いちゃうんすよね
これなんかお腹空いたとか言ってるんですかね
なんか一週間くらい餌をあげなくても大丈夫みたいです
あげますけど
ああいいですね
こういうイラスト見たらなんかよしよしってしたくなりますね
あーあ
ひとまず準備します
わあこれですね
まずはこれを水で洗ってきます
水で洗ってきました
こっからですね、まず足を着けます
２番目の線までまず水を入れます
よしOK
こちらの海の水の素を入れます
あああうわああああうわあ
えーえーこれ大丈夫？めっちゃ濁ったんだけど
次にこれを割り箸などでよくかき混ぜます
で、この後すぐ卵を入れたいところなんですけど
多分１日待ちます
１日待って多分カルキ抜きしなきゃ駄目なので
２４時間後に会おう
ｶｵﾎｫﾆｬﾆｬﾆｬはい１日経ちました
どうでしょう、昨日と比べて透明度が全然違いますね
多分これで大丈夫なはずだと思います
これいつも思うんですけど
透明だと見にくいんすよね
最初小さいから分かんないから
なんか頑張って黒くします背景を
よしなんか多分これを貼り付ければなんとかなるっしょ
あ見やすいんじゃない？見やすいっしょ
多分背景黒くしたんで
これで大分観察しやすくなったと思います
では卵を入れていこうと思うよ
一振りだけ入れるんだ……
え！？一振りで良いの
なんか結構沢山入ってるように見えるんですけど
一振りで良いらしいです
えー一振りで良いんだ
ってことは何回でも育てれるってことか
よしじゃあ早速卵を入れていきましょう
一振りだけ入れますよ
せーのはっ
え
あOKもうもう入った入った
多分入った多分入った
細かっ
やばいやばいちょ待てこれ大丈夫かな
この水面に浮いてる黒い点々が卵です
え、こんなに少なくていいの
浮いてるんだけど
浮いてるよこれ間違いな
え、これ大丈夫？大丈夫なのこれ？
大丈夫なの？これ大丈夫なの？これ大丈夫？
え、これ大丈
分かんないけどちょっと今回は
ちゃんと育てたいと思ってるんで
ちゃんと説明書を見つつ完璧に今回は育てようと思います
で、ポイントとしてはね
直射日…
直射日光を当ててはいけません
水温を３０度超えると
おばけえびが死んでしまうことがあります
で、１日から３日間くらい経つと
小さなおばけえびが産まれてくるらしいです
つまりすぐには産まれない訳ですね
多分明日以降のいつかかえると思うんですけども
ちっちゃな子ども達が見えたら次は餌を与えると
うんOKOK了解しました
ふー次会うときはきっとおばけえびが
成長した姿だと思います
まあいつになるかちょっと分かんないんですけど
なるべく成長するたびに動画撮っていこうと思うので
みなさん　ぷふう　楽しみにしてるんだぜ
じゃあな